welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host the death knight and with
birds-of-prey premiering this week we
have a lot of plot leaks on the movie
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down what apparently happens in
the movie and it's ending this leak
comes directly from reddit and has been
substantiated by a number of sources so
it seems pretty legit obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want anything potentially ruined
about the movie then I highly recommend
that you turn off now all leaks like
this should be taken with a grain of
salt but it does seem very likely and we
wouldn't want to ruin the movie for
anyone who wants to go into the film
with fresh eyes if you're still here
thank you for clicking the video now
let's get into our breakdown of birds of
prey okay so this comes from reddit user
alpha fox run who apparently saw the
film earlier in the week we know that DC
have had several review screenings and
early showings of the film across the
globe and the person behind the post
apparently attended one of these I'm
gonna be taking their breakdown and kind
of rewording it just to make the
sentences flow a bit better and
throughout I'll also be dropping my
thoughts in however if you want to read
the summary in its entirety then I'll
link it in the description below anyway
apparently the movie starts with Holly
eating or writing her origin and cartoon
according to the user the entire movie
is narrated by the character and I did
see this verified by people on Twitter
who complained about this choice
personally I'm not too worried about it
as a lot of films that I love have
narration in them and it can work great
if applied properly in the wake of
Suicide Squad
she has just broken up with Joker and is
taking it badly the character is
completely alone feels isolated and has
been left to our own devices according
to the summary the movie is nonlinear so
elements of the film take place in non
chronological order and certain things
happen at different times and set other
things up that happened earlier in the
movie look just bear with me I'll try
and explain it as best as possible early
on Holly annoys Gotham crime lord black
mask by crippling his driver in a fight
she goes on a several
bender and while Strunk steals a gas
tanker and blows up ace chemicals which
is what we see in the trailer
somehow Renee Montoya is able to know
that Holly did it as a way of getting
over the Clown Prince of Crime and
everyone in this city apparently also
jumps to this conclusion this makes
black mask put a hit out on Holly and
slowly mercenaries go after her we then
cut the Black Canary calling Montoya
saying that everyone is after a young
girl named Cassandra Cain apparently
every time someone is introduced it cuts
to their origin story and we learned
that Black Canary was a lounge singer at
black masks Club after saving Holly from
being sexually assaulted black mask
makes her his new driver and this kind
of ties back to the fight earlier on
canary spends most of the movie as his
driver informing Montoya from behind the
scenes of exactly what's going on in his
operation and this is where they form a
friendship we then cut to Montoya who is
every cop cliche
this isn't me saying this this is a
reddit post by the way I'm not sitting
about slugging women off before you
start Mary Sue I know what you like to
do for cliques
anyway she struggled to EXCI didn't work
due to the trappings of a gender and no
one gives her credit according to the
leak she spends half of the movie and I
shaved my balls for the shirt t-shirt
and then Holly breaks into the police
station wielding a beanbag shotgun from
here we flashback to a time that Holly
was being chased by Montoya Holly steals
an exam which which she was craving and
apparently after the chase scene Montoya
catches up to her and knocks the
sandwich out of her hand
Holly swears revenge and she escapes
from Montoya but is then captured by
Black Mask who managed to catch up to
her black mask threatens to murder her
and she offers to go get Cassandra came
for him after hearing that Cassandra
stole a rare and valuable diamond
apparently Cassie swallowed this and
black mask has put half a million
dollars on a head we don't cut did a
scene from earlier with Holly attacking
the police station with a beanbag
shotgun it's revealed that Cassie is at
the station and this is why Holly is
hunting there Holly finally makes it to
where Cassandra is being held and
accidentally releases all of the
prisoners and they start to run riot she
beats them all up with ballet moves and
gymnastics and then chases Cassandra
through
police station they end up in the
evidence room when a bunch of
mercenaries catch up to them Holley
beats them all effortlessly and then
more mercenaries appear with guns and
she fights them as well
Holley takes cover behind a pallet of
cocaine and as they're shooting at it
vaporizes into the air and she begins
breathing it in due to the high she's
able to disarm all of the gun wielding
opponents and breaks most of their legs
she then tricks Cassandra into trusting
her and then starts teaching her life
lessons after a shopping trip and
introducing her to a landlord Holly
takes her to her apartment where they
eat cereal there's a knock on Holly's
door so she runs to the window and
someone throws a ball of fireworks into
Holly's apartment blowing it up in what
was supposed to be an emotional scene
her pet hyena dies so having no clue
where is falls completely flat again
that's that's the redditor say no not me
you know we'll love animals at the
channel Holly goes downstairs to find
the landlord packing everything up and
he tells her that he betrayed her
realizing that it's everyone for
themselves
Polly decides to turn Cassandra in it's
at this point that we cut to the
huntresses origin story where we learn
that she was the daughter of the crime
lord that originally owned the diamond
that Cassie stole her entire family was
massacred in front affair but Huntress
managed to survive this because one of
the goons helped her to play dead and
then he took her out the country to
raise her she became a trained assassin
and has been hunting everyone that was
involved in her family's death anyway
back in the present Holly sets up a
meeting with black masks in an abandoned
amusement park funhouse black mask sends
canary and his enforcers as to go and
get them according to the summary
because canary is obviously an idiot she
leaves her phone where's oz can see it
the Montoya text says saying that you'll
meet them soon
Montoya Black Canary answers all meet up
with Holly as tries to get canary to
cook Cassandra open but she refuses to
and everyone fights and then Huntress
kills as as it turns out it was a member
of the gang who killed the family black
mask arrives with an army and a fun
house fight scene occurs the user states
this is easily the best part of the
movie and it's one that a lot of people
will enjoy when watching the film they
beat everyone up and then triumphantly
war
of the funhouse and stalking a barrage
of bullets shot them black mask grabs
Cassandra and starts to make a getaway
Black Canary then uses her canary scream
and Holly Quinn who is on roller skates
uses that to propel her towards the car
Huntress comes from out of nowhere on a
bike to help pool Holly along and then
flings Holly towards black mask's car
wrecking her bike in the process
Holly causes Black Mask to crash his car
and he flees with Cassandra to a foggy
Pierre Holly uses her last bullet and
accidentally shoots a statue and
Cassandra shows that she picked pocketed
the pin off of one of black mask's
grenades Holly then throws him over the
Pierre where he explodes with the
grenade midair but where where was
Batman this whole time anyway that
defeats the villains and we get an
epilogue of sorts that wraps up all of
the characters arcs and shows where
things could be heading in the future we
learned that Rene quit the force and
that Huntress used their money to fund
Montoya and Canaries new crime-fighting
team aptly called the birds of prey
Holly pawns the diamonds for cash and
her and Cassandra ride off in the sunset
together
probably off to go film The Suicide
Squad
I'm looking forward to that James gun
you better not let me down now we did
hear rumors earlier in the week that the
post-credits scene was Green Arrow
looking for canary and this got widely
reported I didn't have anyone to verify
it so I didn't cover it but apparently
this scene was made up and Oliver Queen
does not appear in the movie according
to the user there is no real post-credit
scene and grace Randolph did verify this
on Twitter
so it seems true apparently they do sort
of have something to stick around for
though and this continues the narration
of Holly Quinn over the credits she does
a voiceover let's say she knows the
secret and that is who Batman really is
that closes the ending on a cliffhanger
and who knows if we'll ever find out who
Batman really is inside sources say that
Batman is actually Bruce Wayne but I
guess we'll never know make sure you
subscribe the channel for who is the
Batman video coming out this April now
that concludes all of the plot summary
and it's the most detailed one on the
film that could find obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the leaks and
if it makes you excited for the film
we've seen the movie then please let us
know if this is true and if you want to
see more DC stuff then make sure you
check out our breakdown of this week's
big Batman news we go over the top
stories so it's definitely worth
checking out if you're hyped for the
film if you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below your
access to content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made every month we give away free
movies to people who are subscribed to
the channel and this month he can win
dr. sleep and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications on the more videos
your comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winner is gonna be chosen
at random on the 15th of February and
the selfie shipped out from then Toba
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace
you